antoine bonjour alors quel est
l'objectif de cette conférence qui se
tient aujourd'hui dans la capitale
syrienne bien plus de cinq millions et
demi de syriens ont quitté ont fui leur
pays depuis le début des hostilités il
ya maintenant à peu près un peu moins de
10 ans et maintenant avec ce genre
d'initiative le gouvernement syrien
cherche à les faire revenir mais les
obstacles sont nombreux les
infrastructures sont détruites ou alors
en mauvais état il y a également les
sanctions internationales contre la
syrie une situation humanitaire et
sécuritaire parfois délicate dont
certaines régions du pays sans parler
même de l'enclavé d'idleb
toujours sous contrôle terroristes dans
son message d'ouverture de cette
conférence sergueï lavrov a fait savoir
à dénoncer l'existence d'un double jeu
de la part d'un groupe de pays mené par
les états unis on ne venant pas ne
participant pas à cette conférence
aujourd'hui à damas les difficultés sont
donc variées et nombreuses et cette
conférence entend justement trouver des
solutions je vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet l'intervention d'un conseiller du
gouvernement syrien qui a bien voulu
répondre à mes questions écouter pour la
syrie ou pour l'état syrien en tant que
gouvernement l'important c'est assurer
ses infrastructures au moins au minimum
de conditions pour que celles établies
il voit le processus est déclenché on
voit là la reconstruction du pays et le
retour de ces réfugiés dans les régions
de la syrie pas seulement dans les
banlieues de damas ou d'aller dans les
différentes régions sur la géographie de
la syrie est importante assuré
l'électricité le téléphone les logements
etc tous à tous ces problèmes les
conditions initiales pour le retour pose
le problème majeur c'est le vélv et les
sanctions sur la syrie les sanctions au
niveau économique je parle pour le
retour dans les bonnes conditions c'est
à dire rétablir la réfection du monde
des technologies l établir les les
routes les écoles les hôpitaux et cetera
c'est il faut les réhabiliter ces
structures
et cette conférence est donc organisée
par les autorités syriennes avec le
soutien de la russie mais aussi la
participation de 18 pays dont par
exemple le liban qui à lui seul
accueille près d'un million et demi de
réfugiés syriens l'onu et la croix-rouge
sont également présents lors de cette
conférence en qualité d'observateur
contrairement à l'union européenne qui
elle a décliné l'invitation de damas
prétendant que les conditions un retour
des réfugiés en syrie ne sont pas
réunies l'objectif de cette conférence
est pourtant louable tenter de surmonter
les difficultés et les obstacles qui
empêchent les syriens de revenir sur
leur terre natale
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine claireaux en direct
de damas on vous retrouve lors de nos
prochaines éditions